どこにいるの
[音楽]
ここ最近はずっと東京です
こちら初めて超ですはいというわけでここどこかと思う人多いと思うんですけどあの
一応ここ東京です
でというふうに引っ越しました新居ですという動画だしたと思うんですけども
あのちょっと夜中にですね大声でその
ガーって桃鉄やっててちょっとあの大声で叫びすぎたせいで
その物件の管理人さんからちょっとあまりにうるさすぎて浮上が来てねそのも待機をし
てくれという話が来て
まあ
嘘なんですけどちょっと退去とがないですハイあのボートもしっかり見てあのぶっとい
選ばせていただいたっていうの退去とがないんですけども
ちょっとちょっとまだ言えない事情がありまして大丈夫ですちゃんただ近いずに良い
マッサンの地点つに言うんですけどもちょっと理由があって東京南の素晴らしい豪華な
おうち
始めなくなりましたはいど表記する大須ことでしばらく東京にいるんですけども
新居に入れなくなって今このお部屋に住んでおりますあの事情はちゃんとすぐ分かり
ますしあのその悪い以下いいかわあ
これはちゃんと言わんと炎上する奴じゃなぁ
悪くはないです消しバレーじゃないんですけど持ったらちょっと事情があっていいなぁ
ちょっと千葉で帰れなくなっちゃって
で実はここ最近はずっとこの辺に住んでおりますでここは何かと言いますとですね海外
だと有名な詩の日本でも使ってる人は使っていると思うんですけども apa 眠いと
いうものがありましてエア bnb てサイト版
んですけどもそのサイトで何かホテルとかちょあきたんですよ僕駅とで大抵ホテルとか
ホテルとかもうホテルしかないんですよね狭いいいしちょっとしてもたくさんで書く気
遣っちゃうからもっとなんか気楽に入れる場所がないから動画こういうふうに取れない
かってバスを調べてエア bnb っていうサイトを使うと宿泊施設とが民宿とかこと
も積みながら大チっぽいじゃんそういう場所でこの部屋を
針れたってわけなんですよちょっと前からいるんですけども調べたらここがどこかって
すぐ出てくるんですよバレて人が来てもやだからちょっとたぶんこの動画でている時に
はもうねいなくなっていると思ったけどみんな普通にエア日に日で調べて予約したら
ここを泊まれると思うんですけど
まあいわゆるホテルでもなく家具とかも全部揃ってるんですけどおうちにコースみたい
な感じでちょっと一風変わった東京第二お店
しております止めちゃ快適をかけとが全部あるのがすごい助かるんですけど見ていき
ましょう
ん
[音楽]
ねホテルとかだったらたかが知れてるじゃないですかそのベッドがあってフールがあっ
てとか正せるてるからしょうがしないんですけど
完全に人が住めるお部屋がも完成されている状態です見に来てるんでめちゃくちゃ魅力
的なんですよっていうわけで僕が詐欺住んで老兵はこんな感じです見ていきました
うわぁ凄いなんか日本っぽくない作りなんですよねはいて何が多分海外の人が住める
ようにめちゃくちゃ英語で
が入っていますチェックアークタイプ店そしてもさっき見せたんですけど部屋がこんな
感じですね
綺麗でしょと結構鏡音チレーショあとベッドの発芽123456人ぐらいに入れますね
これ以上が一人止まってるわけじゃなくて徹夜と号はい高3人ぐらいには東京来てるん
ですけども
ここは別途すねーわかるこのなんか寮生活館
なんか店ゾーンをされたしすごくないですか5ベッドロッカーから6人は進めるこい
ですね
貼って来て式でもできるしこれもつくんかねぇ
おしゃれやないちょっとオサレじゃないですかえーなんかもう先に家具を置いてある
こういう人のを映すものですね
いわば彼に全部電気つけるとすごいいい感じになりました
僕ですねここにソファーとかもう全部ついてあるんですよねなんか北にはなんか足
マッサージ人はつい
1話が1日さんデカすぎ海外っぽいですねあでここで何かご飯とか食べたりもテレビを
ついてるんでこれでスイッチとかもっさりしてますね洗濯機付きでここらへんの食器と
かも全部ついてますコップとかねすごいよ
わかりやすくなんか甲府いいとか全部書いてある柔軟剤とかも全部ついてます料理とも
前で起訴してよねは折れやすい
んけど調理器具とかもう基本意識そろってますめちゃ意欲ないですかこの雰囲気
例えば借りる時に言われたことがパーティーは禁止だって言われたんでねちょっとこう
いうご時世何で人をたくさん集めるとかできないですけど迷惑にならない程度にはい
すごい綺麗ですね
僕ですねこう今過去がバスルームですねはい
トイレで全部英語で書いてあるこっちがをフローがちょっとねお風呂ついてですけど
まぁ
シャワールームてが付いちゃうだけは見てる感じになってます
あっ僕ですいやいやすげーを全然超いいけど入っておりちょっと分けて今ここで生活し
ております
[音楽]
どうですいや何ならのあの自分の部屋信玄のフォト次世代機たいんですけども
神女いつもよりこう言うねから住み心地の良い音から家具が置いてある部屋のほうが
テンション上がってすみやすいんですよね
直前なエア bnb とを使ったことなかったんですけどカーペットが揃ってるしもう
なんか何でもあるペットがある
[音楽]
木の下から家に住む気を強さすごい真希波ホテルにずっといるよりねば進みやすいなと
思いました
てみたいの出身地入れないなぁちょっとの理由があってなんですけどもそのうち動画で
出るんであのぜひそこはを楽しみにしてください
あったら今あぁただいまをちょっと入れないよって状況でございます
たぶんこの動画だすのちょっと時間になってるから大沢分校が出てると思うんですけど
も幸せな生活を送れています公共静岡の割合が今どれくらいだろう言った1ぐらいかな
ちょっと高はいいんですよね東京にいうの別にそんな人が多いところに行くわけでも
ないんですけど多いから割と室動画に帰ると
今帰ってるかなただ俺基本的に移動とかタクシーだからそんな3つになるような場所に
以下のようにしてるんですけど
まあトレーダーの東京にいる期間時は細心の注意を払って生活したいと思っています
完成している家って
[音楽]
ブーブーえろっちゃんっ
then